angelina jolie brought a very special
plus one to variety's power of women
event her sixteen-year-old daughter
zahara oh
thing i'm thrilled the oscar winner and
an all all-grown up zahara stunned at
the beverly hills red carpet the two
shared a sweet mother-daughter moment
while posing for pics
angelina looked gorge for the rare
public outing with her kiddo in a
long-sleeve light brown gown while
zahara was equally as stunning in an
all-white ensemble and get this the two
also posed it up with honoree amanda
gorman i had to reread this six times
angelina jolie is presenting to you
tonight i know i am also flabbergasted
myself that's incredible i was like i
just thought they were gonna announce my
name and have me go up there but i was
like you're going to have the queen
angelina
it'll be also my first time meeting her
as well but i think she's such a fierce
woman
i can't imagine anyone i'd be prouder to
be standing alongside tonight angie had
the pleasure of introducing the young
poet during the event presenting her
with variety's power of women honor the
young woman of grace who stepped
fearlessly to the podium on inauguration
day
not just the youngest but the strongest
voice we could ask for in that moment
we need voices like amanda's
those lights in the dark
so amanda
may you burn fiercely
and light the way for others
but before angie presented her with the
award amanda opened up to et about
meeting the a-list actress and the
potential of teaming up in the future i
think she's such a strong humanitarian
and that what she stands for typically
transcends the entertainment industry so
i'd love to do something along those
lines i know she's very passionate about
feminism education so those are all my
bread and butter
you